I hereby accept this Charter and
medallion as symbols of the office of
the president of Carnegie Mellon
University this is a very exciting time
for Carnegie Mellon as we meet here
today this university stands as one of
the most remarkable success stories in
20th century American higher education
and we are poised to build much further
Carnegie Mellon in its second century
should be an institution where
pragmatism and practicality merge with
the joy and unfettered discovery and
exploration unlocking new opportunities
for students faculty and staff
it should be an institution that has
both local and global impact one that is
a partner with Pittsburgh's communities
institutions one which has a worldwide
influence
this is indeed a great occasion for
Carnegie Mellon the celebration of our
success in education in research and in
the impact that this institution has on
the world a celebration of our capital
campaign and the progress we've made in
that campaign
that we call the inspire innovation
Randy there will be generations of
students and faculty to come here who
will not know you but they will cross
that bridge we will see your name no ask
those of us who didn't
brandy thank you all that you've done
attorney
so today I guess is the beginning of the
transition of Cyprus's we are a very
welcoming community I've experienced
that beginning 16 years ago
one cannot be a current email without
embracing the tendency to aspire to any
always better and happier in bed that's
the way Carnegie Mellon this own spin
you